famed devout catholic joe biden is under
increasing pressure to answer for his
support of abortion
now that the bishops are actually
holding him accountable to the church's
essential teaching but gensake the white
house press secretary doesn't want to
talk
about any of that does the president
believe that a 15 week old
unborn baby is a human being are you
asking me if the president supports a
woman's right to choose he does
no i love that woman i love that
reporter very simple
does joe biden believe that babies are
babies um do you mean
uh that uh beep boop beep boop that joe
biden supports woman's right to choose
reproductive health beep boop beep boop
people are attacking gen saki for the
euphemisms in the invasion
but we should learn from her we should
learn from the left more broadly
which never accepts its opponent's
language we conservatives do that all
the time
which is why on crucial matters
conservatives have been left
speechless i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from oghani
supreme who says
this is she's she is now speaking as a
leftist
how dare catholics deny us pro-choicers
the eucharist
also leftists people who don't get the
vaccine should not be allowed to leave
their house yes that's true isn't that
so strange
my body my choice when the situation
involves someone else's body and
one needs to have their own private
conscience and not be told by their
bishops
anything about the unity of the physical
and the metaphysical
here on earth communion here on earth
but
if you don't get there if you don't go
along with their orthodoxy
with the orthodoxies of secular
progressivism why then
you are absolutely in trouble and
there's some troubling information
that's coming out about the vaccine
which we will get to
in just a second but you know if you're
if you suffer
from nausea if you if you suffer because
of
whatever anything from hangovers to
chemotherapy you've got to check out
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed
how it works is that relief ban
stimulates a nerve in the wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea then it blocks the
signal that your brain is sending to
your stomach telling you that you are
sick it's amazing technology
if you know someone who deals with
nausea relief band makes a great gift
there are lots of imitators out there
that don't really do anything
relief band is the real deal fda cleared
for whatever reason you're experiencing
nausea this is a great way
to to not let the fear of knowledge keep
you on the sidelines right now relief
band has an exclusive
offer just for michael noel show
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code knowles you will receive
20 off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee head on over to r-e-l-i-e-f
b-a-n-d dot com use your promo code
knowles for
20 off plus free shipping the left is
really good at this
that reporter asked jen saki that
question in as
blunt away as possible does joe biden
think babies or babies
does he think that you shouldn't be able
to kill an unborn baby in the womb
and what does jensaki say she doesn't
blink she doesn't miss a beat she says
are you asking if he supports women's
reproductive healthcare a woman's right
to choose yes he does moving on moving
on
and you're the reporter's like nah
that's not what i'm asking lady stop
using your euphemisms
that's a ridiculous euphemism a woman's
right to choose to choose what
does joe biden support the right to
murder a guy in the street he supports a
criminal's right to choose
right to choose what there's choice is
not the end
in and of itself you can choose good or
evil you can choose things that are
illicit or things that are illicit
but jen saki knows that if she grants
the premise of the question
then they look like moral idiots or
worse
so she can't do that they're always so
rigid on this
the the question is coming up a lot now
because the bishops are really growing a
spine here
and good on them i don't i don't mean to
be derisive about it this is great
that they're standing up to this
nominally catholic president on this
issue
but liberal secularists
you know people on the left are really
really upset about it on the view
whoopi goldberg had a word salad
of euphemism and dishonesty to describe
joe biden's abortion support president
biden often speaks passionately about
his catholic faith
but u.s bishops just overwhelmingly
voted to move ahead
with guidance that could deny him from
receiving the sacrament of holy
communion
because of his presidential support of
women having the right
to choose now you know this this is
something that people were very
concerned about when it came to john
kennedy many years ago
because they were concerned that if you
had a catholic president
you would end up with the with the
with the pope having more say
uh in what should be going on rather
than having the president
who is not just the president of the
catholics he is the president of
everyone uh having you know these
discussions so
i find it amazing that we haven't really
heard much from these
from these gentlemen uh about you know
anything that's going on with children
or parents or
immigration i mean so why do you think
they are targeting him specifically
on this matter sonny isn't this a
political issue
okay this is so confused
whoopi is so out of her depth here but i
suspect this is true of a lot of people
so i don't mean just to single her out
notice in the same breath she's
criticizing the bishops
for being too involved in political
matters
right weighing in too much on this issue
of abortion but also
not being involved enough in what she
thinks should be their role discussing
immigration or any other issue
she's accusing them of being too
political but also not political enough
and she when she's making the first part
of the argument she says the fear when
kennedy was president
is that if if a president were not just
nominally catholic but actually
practiced his faith
were actually faithful to church
doctrine then the pope
would have undue influence in america so
you can't have
some outside authority beyond the
president having undue influence
but this is not just true for catholics
this is true for
any president everybody's got to serve
somebody
if whoopi is afraid that a catholic
president would give too much power to
the pope obviously it's never happened
in american history
didn't happen with kennedy who was a
little loose about his religion or
and it didn't happen with joe biden
who's very loose about his religion but
it's true with everyone joe biden
is nominally catholic actually
progressive
and he's giving way too much influence
not to the pontiff in rome but to the
pontiff
of the potomac dr fauci dr fauci the
the leading authority who joe biden said
could not be fired
no one he would not under any
circumstances fire dr
fauci he would listen to the science dr
fauci is the embodiment of the science
he's the vicar of science on earth
and this man is the not just scientific
but moral ethical political arbiter
everybody's got to serve somebody the
question is what religion are you
following and what priests are you
following the priests of the traditional
religion the priests of the church
or the priests of the laboratory and
progressivism
then whoopi says these bishops why are
the why are they weighing in here
on a question of abortion when they're
not weighing in on immigration first of
all they do weigh in on on these other
sorts of issues
but even accepting
whoopi's premise here abortion is a
different kind of issue
as pope saint john paul ii said abortion
is not just one right among many
or the right to life rather it's not
just one right among many it's not just
like well look
you disagree with the church on abortion
and i disagree with the church on
i don't know taxes or something so it's
all the same right first of all i don't
think the church has a stance on taxes
but certainly not a clear one but even
if that were the case
abortion is the pre-requisite
or life rather is the pre-requisite
right and abortion violates that right
and it's why it is
so specific okay then she makes the
final really stupid point she said
these bishops are not acting religiously
they're acting
politically and chris hahn who is a
democrat employed by fox news
made this same very very stupid point
the other day
get this canard out of your head i know
you've heard it a lot
but get it out of your head the church
shouldn't be political or some
derivation of that we need a firm
separation between
church and state or
religion and politics shouldn't go
together all
politics is religious
all law making
involves morality all states
have some relationship to the church
some relationship to religion because
the state assumes
and enforces certain religious
principles
even in our own enlightened country
a country founded on an idea some people
think the country was founded merely on
an idea
but even that idea that it was
supposedly strictly founded on
presumes the existence of god
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and
endowed by our creator
with certain unalienable rights and
they're not talking about allah
and they're not talking about shiva
they're talking about
the broadly christian understanding of
god
okay religion is political the pope runs
a country
lest you have forget the pope is the
head of a state
okay and politics just means public life
so if you do anything in public i know
that the left wants to relegate religion
to the dark corners of the town in a
little
church on one day a week and even that
they're going to close the church and
they're going to force us all at home
to to really just make religion
something that happens in our own
heads but it is a public thing it
involves
the public megan mccain who is the i
guess the most conservative person on
the view
she came out strongly in opposition
to abortion if you are a devout catholic
as president biden claims to be
abortion is a cardinal sin that can do
deep spiritual harm to you and president
biden
had been supportive of the hyde
amendment up until
2019 when he decided to run for
president and the hyde amendment means
that
the government would provide federal
funding for abortion
or wouldn't and now he is for it and he
has shown in this upcoming
uh budget that he is for it and i think
that sort of has been
the threshold i remember when it
happened um having a conversation with a
friend of mine who was close to him
saying
for me this is a deep paradigm shift for
for how i view
president biden because if he's for the
federal funding
of abortion and i know the women on this
show disagree with me but
as far as i'm concerned abortion is
murder and that means the government
funding
of killing of the unborn and we have to
as uh
pro-lifers fight for the rights of the
unborn and that is a doctrine that's as
old as the catholic church itself so
he has to choose that's true and he does
have to choose you do have to make moral
decisions you do have to own up to your
own
judgments and then move on notice how
clear what megan said was
and notice how garbled what whoopi said
was but the whoopi
euphemisms and the whoopi slogans that's
what's pervaded our culture because the
left
has pushed them they've brainwashed us
and they've rendered us
you might say speechless not just but
where's my bill
do i not get there we go they rendered
us speechless not just by
overt censorship but by a sort of
pre-censorship that that
warps our thoughts and turns us into
putting heads you know
if you want to protect against all sorts
of crazy stuff you
definitely need to get ring there are a
thousand reasons
to protect your home all your stuff
first of all
and all your family that's another thing
and maybe you want to protect against
the bad guys who could come over
maybe you want to protect against your
in-laws i don't know they're
i'm just throwing it out there you want
to know who's at your doorstep
and you can you can do that with ring
ring allows you to see and speak to
whoever is at your door it actually
allows you
to control every inch of your home
whether you
are in your home whether you are at your
office
whether you are on the road you know i'm
on the road sometimes i love to know
that sweet little elisa and cute little
baby june that
little bundle of joy can know who is on
the other side of the door before
they open that door it gives me peace of
mind gives me peace of mind that my
friends
can be safe knowing that i gave them
this as a housewarming gift
and i can be happy knowing that i didn't
pay that much money because it's not
very expensive
start protecting your home today with a
ring alarm go to ring.com knowles
to get your ring alarm security kit
today you can build the system that's
right for your home have it up and
running in minutes that's ring.com
knowlesring.com knowles the the ladies
on the view with the exception of megan
mccain
are denying the humanity of babies in
order to shill for joe biden
who is scandalously in violation of
sure the church is teaching the church
that he claims to
belong to but they're not the only ones
biden's not the only one speaking of
denying humanity
don lemon is making some pretty
audacious claims
in the washington post he just gave an
interview and he's
gone back to this race hustling
narrative that has been so successful
for the left and he says that white
people
do not see black people as fully human
here's the line he says we're living in
two different realities as
black and white people it's a very
important idea
we're living in two different realities
as black and white people
i feel like i've had to to do that to
speak out on these issues because i
don't think america has seen enough
people like me
i don't think america intimately knows
enough people like me
i would love america to see black people
especially black gay men
as and i hate this word normal and as
human beings and as part of the culture
that we have our vulnerabilities and our
struggles but we also have our successes
we love we hurt
and we go through trials and
tribulations just like anyone else what
is this the merchant of venice what is
that
does a done lemon not bleed does a don
lemon not feel i don't know if america
sees black people and especially black
gay men
as fully human and as deserving of the
american dream
you know don lemon is wrong about a
great many things and he's extremely
whiny and his perception of the world is
extremely
distorted and wrong but he's right on
this point
he's right on this point the mainstream
view in america
which is dictated by the left because
the left controls the institutions
and therefore controls our words and
controls our minds you might say
thank you the mainstream view on the
left is that black people
are not fully human of course they're
not that
the according to the intersectional left
and you know intersectionality is is one
component of critical race theory
this idea that oppression
sort of multiplies upon itself so a
black guy is oppressed and a woman is
oppressed but a black woman is
especially oppressed
and a black woman is oppressed and a
gay person is oppressed but a black
lesbian is especially oppressed
and a black lesbian is oppressed and a
muslim is oppressed but a black lesbian
muslim is especially oppressed right and
there's
no end to this this hierarchy of
victimhood
according to that radical ideology the
only fully human people
are straight white guys specifically
straight white guys
who know that they are guys who are
christian who are you know that kind of
goes in the other direction as well
the reason for that is according to this
radical leftist ideology
white guys are the only people that
possess free will and
intellect according to the the left
the will of all non-white non-male
people has been compromised by the
oppression
and the outright enslavement
at the hands of white guys and so that
takes care of your will and as for your
intellect for the handful of black
conservatives or woman
conservatives or homosexual
conservatives or
this that or the other thing they are
actually
not conservative they're just totally
diluted and brainwashed they're laboring
under
what the western marxists would call a
false consciousness
this is a term that became very popular
during the second wave of feminism in
the 1970s
that you would have these wine and
cheese soirees as i call them w-h-i-n-e
these women perfectly happy
well-adjusted women would go hang out
with their radical witchy friends
and they'd go complain about their lives
and then and this is written about
in a very famous essay called the
personal is political something to that
effect
i write about it at length in my
upcoming book speechless which is
available for order today
i think you can still get a signed copy
but i'm not sure we have a live signing
event tonight so you can check it out
then
uh these soirees would involve women
going
they were perfectly happy with their
families and their husbands and their
kids and then they leave and they would
actually say wow i had no idea how
oppressed i was
man i'm furious now i'm really i'm
really upset this is terrible
so that false consciousness
alleged false consciousness is what the
radicals in the western marxist
tradition that
gives us political correctness and
wokism and cancer culture
that is what they're fighting against
now
in in my view the perfectly happy
well-adjusted women were not operating
under a false consciousness they were
actually
happy and well-adjusted and now because
of the advent of this insane ideology
that is actually forcing them under a
false consciousness because they believe
people like don lemon believe
that they are repressed someone can be
speaking on cnn
can be a very wealthy very famous guy
who is only given uh wonderful adulation
in the culture
in the mainstream culture who has places
that he goes to in the hamptons
and he can pretend that he's oppressed
to me
i don't know i'm no expert it would seem
to me that that view is the false
consciousness
not the other one but he is right on the
narrow point
in the mainstream culture which is
dictated by the liberal
establishment only white men are seen as
fully human
that's not the fault of conservatives
that's not the fault of trump supporters
that's not the fault of white men
it's the radicals on the left who are
pushing that idea
this racial ideology is forcing some
really
funny ideas uh you know they're it's
dark and it's sad but it's still funny
you have to laugh at it
lin manuel miranda he's the broadway guy
who
wrote hamilton he's the broadway guy
who wrote in the heights a very
important figure
in the current new york theater scene
lin-manuel miranda now had a movie made
of in the heights
this is a movie exclusively about racial
minorities this is a
this is a movie about dominicans up in
washington heights
he's now been forced to apologize
because the hispanics that he used the
dominicans that he used
were not black enough you know there are
various shades of hispanics just like
there are various shades of all sorts of
people
and the radical left is upset that the
the variety of hispanic that he chose
was
a little too light wasn't dark enough
for their tastes and so instead of
saying
hey you lunatics i made an entire
musical and movie
about racial minorities hey you lunatics
i made another musical where i turned
all the founding fathers black
hey you lunatics i am a left winger
albeit one who sort of seems to like
america at least more than the radical
the real ideologues do
give me a little break here cut me some
slack no
he goes in and apologizes bill maher who
is a liberal but he's a liberal
in a little more of an old school way he
is furious about this and he said
that nothing nothing is ever good enough
for the democrats if lin-manuel
miranda's going to be thrown out
then there's simply no pleasing these
people there's latinx performers
one black lead but no afro latinx
the committee that makes note of
everyone's skin tone
discovered this and then lynn manuel
miranda had to
say i'm truly sorry i'm learning from
the feedback i thank you for raising it
and i'm listening
i promise to do better in my future
projects
this is what i was talking about with
nikki please stop the apologizing you're
the guy who made the founding fathers
black and hispanic
i don't think you have to apologize to
twitter
for sake
this is why people hate democrats it's
cringy
no look he's wrong he's right that it's
cringy he's right that this is insane
he's right that it's so ridiculous but
he's wrong
that this is why people hate democrats
this is why democrats are successful
because they
never give an inch they never go off
script
they never accept republican premises
they never accept the premises of
reality
i'm not just talking republican premises
you know like babies or babies
okay it seems like that's just a premise
of reality but let's go
even further let's go even more to what
we just see with our own eyes
the left will not accept the plain fact
that men are not women
the most controversial line that's ever
gotten me in trouble i've gotten in
trouble for a few lines
most of which in my view have been true
but the one that's really gotten me in
trouble is the idea that men are not
women
and the left insists on this they stick
to their guns
when they're pushing their radical
ideology nobody is safe it's not like
well
hey that's fair we'll meet in the middle
you've gone far enough
that's kind of the republican attitude
the democratic attitude is no
uh uh oh you made a whole musical only
about racial minorities only in this
minority neighborhood
and the whole cast is non-white yeah
they're still too white
yeah all that then how there's no white
people yeah well the non-white people
are still too white
darker go darker lin cry grovel
beg shine my shoes lin
that's the way that they think and
one cannot deny that that strategy
has been successful maybe just
maybe conservatives could learn from
this we make fun of it we should
but we should we should laugh about it
but not in the just dismissive way
that bill maher is laughing about we
need to take it seriously because the
fact is it's been successful
and we should try to be successful too
one place
where you can learn about this strategy
and how to combat it in a way
you know exactly where i'm going control
room
you know exactly where i'm going belle
one way
that you can finally try to turn this
around conservatives have fallen for a
trap we're gonna try to reverse that
is by reading my upcoming book
speechless oh it's not upcoming anymore
it's
it's come it's arrived it's here today
it's available
everywhere bookstores online it also
happens to be amazon prime day
so right now the there it's crazy but
it's changing like every hour
some days you know at some points the
the book is 25
off but every so often they'll run one
of these crazy prime sales where you can
get it for like 40 or even more percent
off so anyway you can check it out on
amazon
you can get it today you can still get a
signed copy of speechless
at premierecollectables.com speechless
before my live signing tonight so i've
got a live signing tonight i know some
people
still wanted to get signed first
editions you can get it but this is your
last chance
so you've got to head on over there
within the next few hours
the book of course speechless
controlling words controlling minds
virtual live signing tonight at 7 30 p.m
eastern 6 30 p.m central and you can go
to premiere collectibles.com
speechless before the signing which
we'll be streaming at dailywire.com and
the daily wire youtube daily wire
facebook
and if you do pre-order a copy don't
forget to type in a question when you
check out
so you can tune in then i can hopefully
answer your question
and if i can't answer it i'll be
rendered speechless and either way
you'll still receive a copy
with my john hancock
premierecollectibles.com speechless and
tune in tonight
at 7 30 eastern we'll be right back with
a lot more
the way that you can know that the
left's political strategy
which is a cultural strategy which is a
religious strategy which is a verbal
strategy right so
i know that we're now supposed to see
huge distinctions between religion and
politics and culture and politics and
this and that it's kind of all
kind of all blends a little bit together
the way you can tell the left has been
very successful
specifically on the word front is how
quickly
radical ideas have been mainstreamed the
clearest example of this
this weight lifter who goes by the name
laurel hubbard i don't know his real
name but he's now going by the name
laurel
he will become the first
transgender athlete to compete at the
olympics
after being selected by new zealand for
the women's event at the tokyo games
this is a decision about the fairness
and the inclusion
this fella is of
a big burly dude okay and he's going to
compete
against very fit women but he's going to
be bigger and burlier than they are
because he's a man
and men are bigger and stronger than
women and i suspect
none of those things that i've just said
are permitted any longer i may be able
to stay on social media but i certainly
wouldn't be allowed to say such a thing
at a
cocktail party or in a corporate hr room
or
in the halls of government or in a
public school we're not really allowed
to say these plain facts anymore
but it is insane that a big burly dude
is going to engage in a weightlifting
competition next to women
and he's going to do very very well and
we're all supposed to pretend that this
is a wonderful
shocking historic thing south park
mocked this idea just two years ago this
was a punchline on south park
just two years ago joining me now is the
current champion of the strong woman
competition
strong woman miss woman do you feel
ready
oh yeah i'm ready david there are just
so many amazing women athletes out here
today it makes me so proud
now this is the first year that a trans
woman is in the competition how do you
feel about that
amazing i feel honored to be a part of
history i have a lot of incredible trans
friends who are athletes and so we're
all inspired this woman's
and uh have you actually ever met
heather swanson
uh no i've never competed against her
before no she's not exactly your average
trans athlete
well what is an average trans athlete
honestly i find that kind of bigoted
david
okay heather swanson is actually joining
us now
miss swanson how does it feel to be
competing today
i can't tell you how free i feel now
that i've started identifying as a woman
now that i can compete as female i'm
ready to smash the other girls
and is it correct you just started
identifying as female two weeks ago
i'm not here to talk about my transition
i'm here to kick some [ __ ] ass
sir it's still funny right it's still
funny but
now it's not satire
now it's reality that is happening
and it's not just at some random
competition in the middle of nowhere
that is happening at the olympics now
that guy maybe without the beard
is this but this giant burly dude
with big muscles is going to be
competing against a woman
and we're all going to have to pretend
that that's totally normal and fine
and good actually and then when he
does very very well at the competition
uh we all have to pretend that that's an
amazing historic thing
sometimes you'll hear from the left that
no
there is no evidence that trans women do
any better
or have any unfair advantage against
real women
they wouldn't call them real women
they'd say it's just another variety of
women
that is just fake there was a random
twitter account called rip
x for nutmeg that posted a little thread
on this last night
just and this is just a handful we do
not have time to go through all of the
examples
uh 1998 to 2012
laurel hubbard that guy who's now going
to be at the olympics
failed to qualify for a single
international men's tournament
as a professional weightlifter 2013
hubbard transitions quote unquote at age
35
and from 2014 to 2021 hubbard qualifies
for 11
international women's tournaments
including the olympics i think he got an
advantage
i don't know i'm no expert 2017 cc
telfer is ranked 390th among male
ncaa division 2 athletes in the 400
meter hurdles
in 2018 telfer transitions to pretend to
be a woman
2019 telfer is a national ncaa division
2 women's 400 hurdle champion
2021 telfer hopes to qualify for the
olympics 2013-2015
hannah mouzy made 22 appearances for the
australian men's
handball team scoring zero goals 2015
mancy
transitions in 2018 amid controversy
nancy is allowed to play
six times for the australian women's
handball team scoring
23 goals huh well i think he might think
hannah may have gotten a little
advantage there maybe from
his physique and his biochemistry before
2015 golfer haley davidson won
zero men's tournaments doesn't even look
like he qualified for any tournaments
2015 he transitions 2021 davidson
becomes the first male to win a women's
professional golf tournament 2019 mary
gregory mary
who had transitioned as an adult takes
up just takes it up
professional women's weightlifting and
at his first tournament
won all nine events at the 100 raw
weightlifting federation competition and
broke four world records in the process
just kind of took it up one day but you
know she
transitioned so it was totally totally
kosher you all remember fallon fox
before 2006 fallon fox was in the u.s
navy he's a dude
then he transitioned and then from 2012
to 2014 he becomes an mma fighter he won
all but one of his fights
and in one fight he cracked cracked a
woman's skull open
the list goes on i mean i have so many
more examples of this here do not let
them tell you
that there is no evidence there's never
been an example of a trans woman having
an advantage
over a another woman over a cisgendered
woman it's just not true
they obviously have a built-in advantage
they win or come very close to winning
almost every time under some extremely
extenuating circumstances like like some
some of these guys will take up the
sport
way late but they'll still do better
than the women why because
they're bigger and stronger this is not
only being mainstreamed
at the olympics i don't watch the
olympics i just don't care
i know that you know some people
especially libs really like the olympics
because it's like a kumbaya thing
where we're all supposed to hold hands
and we're all supposed to pretend that
every country on earth is exactly the
same
and even though all the strongest
richest
toughest people and and the and the best
athletes by the way from all the other
countries just come to america because
there's more opportunity here
then we'll kind of send them back or
we'll all try to pretend it's all the
same kumbaya right
i don't go for that i don't really care
however
this radical ideology is not just going
to be the olympics it's going to be
coming to
your veterans hospital
the va is now spending your money your
taxpayer money
to mutilate sexually confused people
wow it's amazing how the military has
changed in recent years
really changed do you remember i mean
bill clinton signed don't ask don't tell
right it wasn't that long ago that
matters of sex
simply were not discussed in the us
military
now your taxpayer dollars
are going to the pentagon and the
pentagon is going to pay to chop
off perfectly healthy appendages on very
confused
men but i suppose some women as well
secretary dennis mcdonough over at the
department of the va
announced at a pride month event that
they will engage
in this surgery but i'm not even talking
about the surgery itself
at the moment you know that is what it
is just listen to the language
the secretary will now spend funds on
quote
gender confirmation surgery because he
says this was
is quote the right thing to do
to meet the surgical needs of
transgender veterans none of those
phrases
mean what he thinks they mean
those phrases are all being used to mean
the opposite of those phrases the gender
confirmation surgery
is being used to to attempt to negate
the gender of these people a gender
confirmation for a man who thinks that
he's a woman
is to i don't know put a baseball hat
and a tank top on him and say you're a
dude
hey bro that's the procedure
you're a man you think you're a woman
well here's a cigar
and you know some grilling utensils you
definitely are a mate we are confirming
your gender
right if you've got the man who thinks
he's a woman
and you mutilate him to make him look
like a woman that is
gender negation surgery that's gender
undermining surgery you can't totally
negate it anyway it's not possible
because it's the right thing to do it's
manifestly the wrong thing to do
our our bodies have a purpose now all
physical things have some kind of
purpose they have a tea loss
so if you're mutilating that and
injuring a perfectly healthy body part
that would be the wrong thing to do and
it does not meet the surgical needs
a perfectly healthy organ has no
surgical needs and if you're going to
chop it up and mutilate it
pump it full of chemicals that would be
quite the opposite
but the left uses this kind of language
and now we all use this language too
we all do it we do you know that reminds
me that bell
of a certain book that you can order not
pre-order you can order right now
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
we all use this language we and it you
know we use the transgender language
we use perfectly conservative people
we'll refer to
bruce jenner as caitlyn and refer to him
as her
and they'll get angry with me when i
don't do that there have been people who
wrote in because i
commented on blair white whom i like
very much blurred white's a very nice
fella
but they're very upset that i won't call
blair white as she and people will write
into me ostensibly conservative people
and they will say
michael why do you have to be a jerk
about it i'm not saying you have to
believe that blair is a woman
you know blair is this man who
identifies as a woman you don't need to
believe that blair is a woman but you
don't need to be a jerk
and call him a man hold on you're
telling me i'm a jerk because i'm
stating a plain fact because i'm telling
the truth
if i tell the truth i'm a jerk but what
if i lie i'm compassionate
i'm a nice guy i don't think that's true
i think that's a
left-wing premise that you have
unwittingly adopted well michael look
blair doesn't think that he's a woman
but you can at least refer to him as a
woman
as as i'm doing it's she buddy
no that's the i don't i really don't
my problem is not with blair white or
bruce jenner for that matter
my problems with you because you're
adopting that language
and you're insisting that all the rest
of us live in lies as well
and when you do that when you accept the
pronoun
which you and i'm speaking broadly to
the squishy conservative types out there
or even the
honestly naive types out there when you
say the pronouns are not a big deal when
the left says the pronouns are not a big
deal
the more you say it the more intensely
you say it the more i'm convinced it is
a big deal
the more the left spends its time and
resources and money
trying to get us all to use the wrong
pronouns the more i'm convinced
that it's a big deal because the left
obviously thinks that it is speaking of
dubious medical treatments
there's a headline here i'm probably not
even allowed to read this headline
it's a headline that came out says 19
year old college freshman dies from
heart problem one month after second
dose of modern vaccine
i have heard many of these stories
anecdotally
people who not who have died necessarily
but people who have had serious
adverse reactions after having had the
vaccine
some of which were pretty dire some of
which required hospitalization
and this is just from friends of mine
and certainly from many friends of
friends but
the plural of anecdote is not data we
are told and i'm sure that you've heard
of people like this too
and we've seen a lot of news stories
about this of teenagers and people in
their 20s suffering from myocarditis
inflammation of the heart after
receiving the covid vaccine
and yet we are still told we all have to
get the covet vaccine we know
that this is an experimental drug
that is being pushed on us by the media
by
the medical establishment by the public
health authorities by
the government by big tech by everybody
why my argument on the vaccine is not
that it's going to cause us all to grow
a tail and get better cell reception
with all the 5g going through our blood
right it's not on that side of it
necessarily
it's also not on the side that we all
need to get the vaccine my argument is
make a prudential judgment if you're not
at great risk
why would you do it i don't i don't see
why i would do it i don't see any
i might have to do it in order to travel
i might have to do it because the
establishment
is making it so onerous that one cannot
live one's life
right so i suppose that that factors in
too but just as a purely medical matter
i don't see any reason why a young
person would get this thing
and i suspect the liberal establishment
would agree with me in private
in fact i sort of know that they would
the public health authorities are
forcing as best they can
everybody to get these vaccines no
matter what risk they have from the
covid itself the public health
authorities that have lied to us
about virtually every aspect of this
virus
lied to us about their views of the
masks lied to us about the relationship
to the wuhan laboratory
lied to us about the manipulation by
human beings
of this virus that we were told was
naturally occurring they've lied lied
lied lied
lied now we are told hey take the
experimental drug
you have to and if you don't you're
anti-science if you don't you're killing
grandma or something
the public health authorities are
forcing perfectly healthy people
at very low risk to do it and yet and
yet
when when that guidance interferes with
their other political priorities they
totally ditch it
so for instance there's a rule
called title 42 this is a trump era
policy that permitted
immigration officials to turn back
illegal aliens
because of the pandemic you'd think we
could turn down illegal aliens because
they're illegal aliens and they
shouldn't be coming into our country
you think we'd be able to do that but
no this country is so beyond the
the scope of law and order at this point
that we're not allowed to do that
unless we invoke this special provision
and say hey guys
i i'm so sorry that mr coyote that we
have to uh
actually enforce our laws right now but
we just told everyone that there's a
super duper dangerous global pandemic
that's going to kill everyone if they
leave their homes
so would you mind just if you if you go
home for a little bit and then maybe
come back
a little bit later well the biden
administration isn't even going to
continue to enforce that according to
reports
they're just going to let everyone come
in so you're telling me you're telling
me that the virus is so super-duper
dangerous that we can't leave our house
for a year
more year and a half you're telling us
that it's so super duper dangerous that
perfectly healthy people need to get the
experimental drug
that's had all of these anecdotes
associated with it of of
adverse side effects but then you're
telling me that the
pandemic is so innocuous you're telling
me that the virus is so
uh without danger that we're just going
to flood the country with illegal aliens
who are untested who
are carrying any number of viruses with
them
which is it which is it's contradictory
because it's not about
any medical fact it's obviously about
political power
this is probably not going to play well
with voters there's some encouraging
news
out of the western conservative summit
on the issues that are really affecting
conservatives
the top five most important issues
according to a straw poll at
this western conservative summit are
immigration and border security
82 election integrity with 79
religious freedom with 75 percent the
federal budget and deficit with 74
and gun rights 74 notice what's not on
the list
what's not on the list is
tax cuts for multinational corporations
conservatives aren't that concerned
about that republican officials might be
concerned about that but
uh actual conservative voters are not uh
making
juneteenth a federal holiday that's it's
it's not on the list i'm looking
the five most important issues you'd
think that making juneteenth
a federal holiday would be out it's not
so weird because it passed unanimously
in the senate and all but i think 15
republicans in the house voted for it
and yet it doesn't it doesn't show up it
doesn't make it
you'll notice that letting men into the
ladies room
that's not on the list that's so strange
what is on the list
immigration enforcing our basic laws
having a country
that's what that means right if you have
if you don't have a border you don't
have a country
election integrity all republicans don't
want to touch that with a 10-foot poll
we're not allowed to talk about that are
we
we're not allowed to say that maybe
there was something a little weird about
the 2020 election
maybe it's a little weird that states
violated their own election laws
in the case of pennsylvania violated the
state constitution are we allowed to say
that no maybe i'll be kicked off youtube
maybe i will be rendered speechless i
don't know
thank you it's a little slow but we got
it on time
now there's something else coming out of
this western conservative summit
in the straw poll governor ron desantis
who's obviously running very hard for
the presidency right now
he came out on top he won
the straw poll for who conservative
voters at this summit want to see as the
nominee in 2024.
he beat out president trump
this is pretty big stuff so the top five
candidates in order of
highest approval to least ron desantis
followed by donald trump followed by
ted cruz followed by pompeo followed by
tim scott
this might create some difficulties
uh desantis and trump get along very
well right now it would appear
but if if desantis is a real threat to
trump and trump really wants to run
again that could create some problems
also worth pointing out ron desantis i
look he's doing great stuff i don't want
you to misinterpret what i'm saying as a
knock on desantis
he's really doing an excellent job in
florida i'm just pointing out a fact
of the presidential process he has not
been at the national level for very long
yet and so
it's he's got to go through the ringer
in order to really
for people to know that he's a really
strong candidate he has to win
re-election next year in florida
and he's he's going to have a serious
race he's going to have a very
well-funded democrat nikki fried who's
the current ag commissioner
running against him so he's gonna have
to focus on that for a little bit if he
can make it through that if he can make
it through the first stages
of the primary process then he's gonna
be a tougher candidate
is trump gonna start attacking him i
don't know but the thing about someone
like trump
or someone like cruz is they really have
been through the ringer obviously
they're
at this point they're pretty tough
they're pretty teflon
so you you could see an interesting
dynamic where
trump and desantis are running in the
same lane if cruz runs i don't have any
special knowledge i know i host a show
with a guy but i don't
you know i'm not telling any tales out
of school if he runs and i have
encouraged him to
he's kind of in his own lane pompeo i
think would kind of be in his own lane
because he'd be running
from the foreign policy side and tim
scott is from the more moderate ring of
the party so he'd be in his own lane
the trickier thing is for trump and
desantis because they're really both
going
for the same the same lane mike pence
actually
believe it or not was heckled at the
faith and freedom conference that just
went on
people are very upset that he did not
stop the
ratification of the electoral votes in
2020
that might harm him who knows if he's
going to run or not it seems like he may
run
there is some good news coming out of
georgia also gotta get this in
georgia is preparing to cut a hundred
thousand names from its voter rolls
as a list maintenance effort there are
just a lot of people who moved out of
state who died who are still on the
voter rolls
they need to be cut off we're going to
be told that this is an attack on voting
rights in our democracy
no don't do it don't give in don't use
their language
gotta fight tooth and nail folks
otherwise it doesn't matter how good our
candidates are gonna be
in 2022 or 2024 if they control
the political process if they control
the established institutions
if they control our words if they
control our minds they will leave us
speechless go order don't pre-order
order speechless today thank you to
everyone who was pre-ordered
really appreciate it i really want to
stick it in the nose
in the nose is that an expression i
really want to stick it in the eye of
the squishy republicans i really want to
stick it in the eye
of perhaps even the new york times
bestseller list let's let's try to do
that that would be
extremely delightful and i hope that it
will help us start winning in the future
i'm michael nolsas the michael knowles
show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
board
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show
senator sheldon whitehouse gets caught
with his hand in the racist cookie jar
but faces no consequences
democrats begin to walk back their
radical voting proposals and new york
city votes for mayor that's today on the
bench parish i'll give it a listen